in this game dev course you will learn
how to create an endless runner game
using unreal engine and c plus fah here
teaches this course he has created a ton
of game development tutorials and he is
an excellent teacher what is up guys fi
here and back again with another unreal
engine tutorial this time a c plus plus
one yes because a lot of you do see
okay i'm going to do a c plus plus
tutorial anyways let us take a look at
the game that we are going to create so
over here i have my editor if i hit the
play button it's a simple side scroller
game so if i you know
jump and all of that stuff you see we
can jump we can move the goal is to
avoid this wall that is chasing us
because if it touches us we're going to
die and of course we're going to have
obstacles along the way such as these
platforms such as the spikes that we are
hopefully going to see pretty soon
because they are not spawning all of
this time there we go we have the spikes
if we touch the spikes bam we are dead
the level is going to restart if the
wall hits us bam we are dead the level
is going to restart
as you can see it looks like a basic
game but we are going to learn a lot of
cool things especially c plus plus wise
because we are going to do all of this
in c plus from scratch coding everything
and you are going to see me code and you
know you're going to enjoy that and
learn a lot and yada yada yada anyways
what else can i say let's jump into this
course yeah it's a mini course what else
is you know it's a mini course okay it's
tutorial mini course whatever let's jump
into it and create this cool game
alrighty then my game develops now that
we saw the game that we are going to
create let us create the game so over
here i have the unreal engine project
browser we are going to click here on
games and by the way this is unreal
engine version
4.25 and we are going to select our
third person project so not the blank
one but the third person because we need
some elements from that you know third
person package and over here we're going
to click on x and from blueprint i'm
going to click on the drop-down list and
select c plus plus because yay this is a
c plus plus course and over here i'm
going to name my project i'm going to
call it side runner cpp of course you
can think of something more creative
than that i'm going to click here create
project and wait until the project is
created and then i am going to come back
and here we are finally so now what we
are going to do is we are going to
create the player and specifically the
player class over here by the way i have
this engine content we will use that as
well if you don't have it you are going
to click here where it says view options
so this right here that i draw so click
on that and from there you're going to
click this checkbox show engine content
so make sure that that is checked and
then you will be able to see what i see
in my project also one neat trick if you
find that all of these elements inside
of the editor are too small especially
if you have a big monitor you can go
over here under under window and then
developer tools and then you can go over
here widget reflector and let me just
bring that bad boy over here and this is
the scale for the application usually i
set it at
1.16
and it is going to rescale my
application basically make it a little
bit larger and that stuff so that i can
see more better
that's all there is to it anyways going
over here in the content i'm going to
right click and create a new folder that
i am going to call maps because over
here we're going to create a new map and
that is going to happen under file and
the new level basically new level i said
map but that's the same thing ctrl s to
save it i'm going to save it over here
and i am going to call this one gameplay
and there you go so the first thing that
i'm going to do with this gameplay is
i'm going to remove the floor that we
have over here so simply delete it and
there you go and next i'm going to go
here into geometry and meshes and i'm
going to take this template floor and
place it over here and there you go let
me just position this bad boy so for the
x is going to be zero for the y it's
going to be zero z is going to be 20 and
i am also going to rescale it so i'm
going to click here on this lock icon to
lock the scale and i'm going to say 0.25
and there you go rescale it and voila
also in regards to the player start
position let me just click on that yeah
it is going to be where it is and this
is where we are going to
spawn our player
now before we proceed to create the
player class over here inside of the
project settings and in the input we are
going to have some mappings and axis so
basically we only need the jump so i'm
going to delete this reset vr simply
click here on this x and delete it here
we are going to have move right we're
not going to have move forward and all
of these stuff so look up look rate turn
turn rate and move forward we're going
to delete all of these and leave only
all of these of course you can also
filter these so we don't need the
gamepad i basically only need the space
bar but again that is up to you
depending on if you want to create maybe
you want to practice or whatnot i don't
know i'm not you i'm not you know i'm
not controlling you and stuff like that
so there you go so we should have jump
and move right for the jump we have the
spacebar for the move right a and d you
can also add the you can also add the
left and right that is totally up to you
i am not going to go in there you know
do not judge me
so
now we can go over here inside of our c
plus plus so c plus plus classes and
from there there you go
here we have our side runner cpp
character i am not going to use that one
i'm simply going to right click and go
here new c plus plus class it is going
to inherit from the character i'm going
to click on next
and i am going to call this one runner
character and hit the create class
of course you know that it takes a while
for unreal engine to you know compile
and load all of this i am going to get
an m2 ssd just because of this like i'm
not kidding just because of this i'm
getting an s m2 excuse me ssd that can
read for i believe three
3005 megabytes per second so that is
what i'm getting okay this is what i'm
going to get and finally here is my
class so we have the runner.h file and
the runner.cpp file if you don't know
the difference between the two i'm
quickly going to explain so in the dot h
file we declare everything that we need
and inside of our cpp file we then code
all of that that we have declared
simple yes it is so what do we need over
here right below where it says our
generated body i am going to declare i
you property so it's property there you
go sometimes i cannot spell and i'm
going to call it visible anywhere there
you go and this one is going to be our
class this is called a forward
declaration when you type a class so
that we don't have to include the file
over here and i'm going to say you
camera component and it's a pointer so
we need to denote that with the star and
i'm going to call this one side view
camera now as i said this is called a
forward or forward declaration i believe
i'm not 100 sure because i'm not good
with those names i don't care but
essentially what is the point of this is
that we declare it with a class over
here so that we don't have to use the
include over here you see because every
single thing that we use for example if
we want to use
functions from the character we need to
include the game framework character but
i don't want to do that for the camera
component because every time you include
the runner.h file anywhere in your class
or in any other class that is
then it will include all the includes
that come with it but when you use it
like this then
it will not include them but inside of
here runner dot or runner character.cpp
then we are going to include it and that
is the better way to go so over here
this is you know the constructor for our
character the begin play and all of the
good stuff tick and set up player input
component so we are not going to touch
any of those instead what i'm going to
do is over here protect it and over here
i'm going to declare my own functions
and variables first things first i am
going to declare here void move right
and this one is going to take a float
value as a parameter and of course in a
moment of two it is going to start
complaining with a green line below this
move right because we didn't declare it
inside of the dot cpp file don't worry
about that we will do it in a few
moments so over here we're also going to
create a public and this one is going to
return are you camera component and
again it is a pointer and i'm going to
call this one get
side view so get side view camera
component
and this one is going to take a constant
or actually it's a constant and it is
going to return
the side view camera simple as that
next we are going to have another public
function that i'm going to call void
restart
level this is going to happen at the end
when our player gets killed which is
something that we saw as well
also what i'm going to create and this
is what i said it's going to complain
with this don't worry we will implement
this in a few over here i'm going to
create a new function and this one is
going to be our void on
over lap begin it's going to take a u
primitive so
primitive
component which is a pointer and i'm
going to call this one overlapped
component
comma it also takes an a actor or simply
an actor but it's spelled a actor it's a
pointer and i'm going to call this one
other actor there you go we're also
going to take another primitive
component so i'm going to copy this here
and paste it and it's a pointer so again
we need to use a star over here and
other comp or other components i'm going
to call it it takes an in 32
other body index
a boolean b from
sweep and last but not least a constant
of f
hit result and over here sweep result
there you go
and last but not least a few more
private variables one is going to be the
z position so float z position there you
go it's position like that we are also
going to take an f vector which is going
to be our temporary position that i'm
going to denote is equal to f vector
like that and last but not least a
boolean to denote if we can move
or if we cannot move now of course over
here as you can see it is complaining
for the move right and the restart level
it is not complaining for the on overlap
again but it will start complaining
because i'm still waiting for that ssd
to come so what we need to do is we need
to declare this function over here
inside of our runner character dot cpp
file so we need to as i said declare it
and that can happen by going over here
and declaring and typing it you know
void a runner character column colon and
so on and so forth but there is a
quicker way to do this what we can do is
we can click on this move right and i
can right click and then i can go here
quick actions and refactoring and over
here i can say create declaration
definition and there you go when i click
on that it is going to create it of
course you know this hdd
drive it's driving me nuts
and
i will probably have to cut out this
video because you know if i sing to you
that will cost you extra i mean this is
on youtube you don't pay anything for
this
but uh there you go finally okay so now
if i go here in the runner there you go
so we have the void runner move right we
can do the same thing for this over here
so we can you know do the same thing for
the restart level by typing void a
runner character column call on move
right but instead of that i'm simply
going to right click again quick actions
and refactoring and i'm going to create
a definition for it and last but not
least we need to do that for on overlap
begin so quick actions refactoring
create declaration there you go save
this over here save this over here and
voila here are the functions that we
need so from here there you go
so what are we going to do
when it comes to our runner character
well for our runner character here is
where i said that we are going to add
those includes so first one i'm going to
include
and that one's going to be components
there you go it's components
and then backslash and this one's going
to be capsule
component dot h
and i'm going to include everything that
we are going to use so over here we're
also going to include in quotes game
frame
work
and then backslash
spring actually we don't need the spring
r component we need a camera so i got
carried away usually when you use the
camera use the spring arm but i'm simply
going to use the camera without it so
camera dash or backslash camera
component dot h there you go
and also include and over here game
frame work so game frame work actually
yeah it's capital framework like that
and backslash
character
movement component
and there you go actually dot h and now
there you go
so this is the or these are the includes
that i was talking about when i forward
declare the camera component so instead
of using this camera component include
over here
i'm simply going to forward the clear it
like this and then over here i'm going
to use the include because if we need to
use the runner character in some other
class and we need to include the runner
character.h file
when we include that it will not include
this import because this import is
inside of the dot cpp file
so over here inside of our runner
character which is the constructor
basically what we are going to do first
we are going to set the capsule
component so i'm going to say get
capsule component
and from there i'm going to say init
capsule size and the size is going to be
42
on the x
and 96
on the y there you go i'm also going to
set the channel to respond to collision
with overlap basically setting
the collision settings to response with
overlap so over here i'm going to say
get capsule component so get capsule
capsule component there you go
and over here i'm going to say set
collision response
to channel
and from here
going down i'm going to say ecc
underscore
game trace channel
and it's going to be trace channel one
and i'm going to say a c r
over
lap there you go
and moving forward
we are going to denote that we
are not going to allow the controller to
rotate us instead we are going to use
our own or basically we are going to
control this class from within itself so
i'm going to say here b
use control rotation pitch that is going
to be equal to false
i am also going to simply copy this
and paste it past paste it and this one
is going to be pitched then we're going
to have the roll and last but not least
we're going to have the yaw basically as
i said this is not going to allow the
controller to rotate
the controller is not going to rotate
this character instead we are going to
do that from within this class and since
this is a side scroller where i'm going
to rotate and all next i'm going to
create the camera so our side view
camera is going to be equal to create
default sub object and it's going to be
type of view camera component like that
and i'm going to give it a name by
passing here a text
and that name is going to be side view
camera simple as that there you go
nothing you know complicated i'm also
going to or
i don't want the controller to rotate
the camera as well so i'm going to say
side view camera and over here i'm going
to say be use pawn control rotation that
is going to be false so this is not
going to allow the controller to rotate
the camera
next i'm going to set the character
movement to face the direction that we
are moving to so if we are moving to the
or in this case because the game is a
side scroller we can move forward or we
can move backwards so that is why i'm
going to say over here
get
character movement and from there i'm
going to say b orient rotation so orient
rotation to movement that is going to be
equal to true which is basically going
to allow us as i said to rotate towards
the direction where we are going now
this is going to be the rotation rates
i'm going to say get character movement
but i'm going to copy it because we're
going to use it a few times over here
and i'm going to say here rotation rate
and that's going to be equal to f
rotator
and over here i'm going to say 0 for the
x
720 for the y and 0.0 f for the z now if
somebody is confused if this is your
first time seeing unreal engine c plus
plus code first things first i am
advising you to go through my c plus
tutorial series here on youtube you have
that in my academy as well but what i
wanted to say is if you're confused why
i'm using here 0.0 but over here 720
point and i don't add zero what is the
difference well there is you there isn't
actually so you can add zero you can
emit zero it's the same exact thing
so that is when it comes to the rotation
rate and i'm going to actually point 0
here
and move this backwards and there you go
so next we're going to set the gravity
scale for our characters so i'm going to
say gravity
scale that is going to be equal to two
i'm also going to set the air control so
air control is going to be equal to zero
point f air control is basically how or
or the
how much control of our character do we
have while he is in the air the higher
the number the higher the control
next we're also going to say here our
jump z velocity is going to be equal to
a thousand
that's basically going to be you know
how far or how high we can jump next
over here i'm going to say ground
friction is going to be equal to three
and ground friction is basically you
know the collision with the player and
the ground also over here i'm going to
set the max walk speed that is going to
be equal to 600
and last but not least max fly speed
that is going to be equal to also 600
and there you go and now we are going to
get our temporary positions i'm going to
say temp pose that is going to be equal
to get actor location which is the
current location of our actor or
basically the game character and i need
this temporary position because i'm
going to say our z position variable is
going to be equal to temp position dot z
plus 300
point zero there you go
and now what do we or
what do we need to do we need to bind
we need to bind our controls if we want
to move the character so over here we
have our setup player input and this is
where we are going to bind the axis and
the jumping and all of the good stuff so
now we have this player input component
that is passed over here in the setup
input component so i can simply use that
and i can say player input component
which is you know called as you can see
to bind functionality to input so i'm
going to say over here bind
action so bind action and i'm going to
bind the jump
action and how where or what
where do i have this jump action well
the jump action is over here if i go
into the project here it is action
mappings and this is the jump action so
this name needs to match up with the
name over here that we specify so bind
that to
and of course because this is an action
we can press it and release it so i'm
going to say ie pressed basically what
do we want to do when we press the jump
button well over here we're going to
bind it passing this as well and over
here a
character
column call on jump there you go so
essentially when we press the jump
button or
in our case the jump button is denoted
with the space bar so when we press the
space bar we're going to call the jump
functionality from the character that we
have inherited because this class
inherits from the character you see here
public a character
and the character has some built in
functionality such as jumping so i'm
also going to copy this because when we
release it we are going to so this is e
i e pressed and over here i e released
so when we release the jump button
instead of jumping we are going to stop
jumping
this will stop the jumping of the player
and he will start to fall down simple as
that next i'm going to take the player
input component and now i'm going to
bind the axes instead of binding the
action and i'm going to bind the move
right
and i'm going to bind it to this
referring to this class and referring to
the a
runner character column colon move right
there we go so this right here is going
to bind to the move right which is again
going back over here this is that move
right it is going to bind to our move
write function which is this function
over here so essentially now
over here in our move right
we are going to add the code that is
going to move the player so over here we
are going to test if can move and we are
going to use this to denote if the
player can move when he is dead we will
see that later on but if the player can
move we're going to say add movement
input and from here i'm going to say f
vector
so it's f vector
and over here zero movement on the x on
the y is going to be one and on the y or
actually on the z it's also going to be
zero and over here i'm going to pass the
value that we have now in order for this
to work we do need to denote inside of
our begin play that can move so can move
is going to be equal to true this is
when we start our game which is you know
normal and all of the good stuff
otherwise it will not work so i'm going
to hold ctrl shift and press b this is
going to compile my code and of course
we're going to wait a few moments i
don't know maybe i will
cut out this video depending on how much
it will take
because again my ssd is still not here i
can also try to sync to you no no no no
no no there you go it worked you see
here build succeeded which means now we
can go inside of our editor and if i
were to go into the gameplay and hit the
play button we do see a character and we
can move
the character but this is not our
character this is the built-in one that
we have that we have created with the
project so in order to create our own
character i'm going to right click over
here and go into the new folder i'm
going to call this some blueprints
and from here i'm going to click and go
inside of that folder and i'm going to
create a blueprint class and i'm going
to inherit from the runner character so
here is my
runner
character and i'm going to click on that
one and i'm going to say bp
runner
character so this is now our character
this is going to create our character
from the class that we have just created
of course as you can see we don't have
anything we do have the side view camera
you see we have created it over here but
what we need to do is we need to click
on the mesh and over here we need to add
a skeletal mesh which is basically going
to be our mannequin which is this bad
boy over here i'm also going to set his
z location to negative 97 to lower him a
little bit down as you can see and i'm
going to rotate him 90 or minus 90
degrees like that
and basically that would be it i can
compile and save this well one more
thing we do need to attach here a
blueprint class for his animation which
again click on the drop down list and we
have the third person and mvp which
automatically will make him or he will
be animated now in order for us to add
our character right now in the game we
need to create our own game mode because
if you remember from the previous
tutorial previous unreal engine tutorial
series over here inside of the maps and
modes you see we need to create our own
game mode because currently again if i
hit the play button this is not our
character you see this is not the
character that we want
instead over here i'm going to right
click and blueprint class and i'm going
to filter from game mode or filter for
game mode and click here and inherit
from game mode it's going to be our bp
runner or side runner excuse me side
runner underscore game mode
and let's go over here into the into the
project settings and select the
bp side runner game mode and here
instead of the default pawn i am going
to select the bp runner
character and finally this is going to
allow us to have our own character in
the game so if i hit the play button
there you go if i eject
here he is
now we if i possess him we have a
problem you see we don't see the
character we don't see anything
and the reason for that is we can move
him if i don't know if you notice pay
attention where he is currently if i
possess him and if i move like this i'm
moving and let's try to see where he is
now
you see he almost fell down so there you
go
okay so what do we need to do in order
for this or to make this work
well we need to go back in our c plus
plus class and over here where it says
the tick so inside of our tick
functionality we need to say our temp
position so temp pos is going to be
equal to get actor location again we're
getting the actor location our temp
position dot x
is going to be equal to or we're going
to subtract from it 850
like this
and on the z position so temp position.z
is going to be equal to z position so z
position and last but not least our side
view camera
set world location over here we're going
to pass the
temp
position and there you go
so what this is going to do it's again
going to get the current actor location
the current actor location is basically
well the actor location
just kidding but the current location is
the location of our own actor of the
character we are going to then change
the x position so subtract from it 850
and the z position is going to stay the
one that we have over here and then
we're going to set that position to the
world location of the camera so ctrl
shift b in order for us to compile this
and by the way i'm not going to do that
but you're going to do it if you want to
see the outcome like if you change this
number to minus thousand minus 100 set
the z position over here i don't know
plus 500
try it out see the outcome that will be
you know
that will be your practice you will
understand more so if i hit the play
button now there you go you see here is
our character he falls down look at that
we
but if he falls down like that we cannot
see him anymore so that's all there is
to it anyways again hit the play button
we can possess the character look at
that we can move over here we can move
over here
that's the point you see and he is
rotating towards the direction where we
are moving if we move backwards you see
he rotates to move backwards if we move
forward he rotates to move forward there
we go we can press space to jump like
that there you go but
the issue is we only have this one
platform
how or what we need to do well we need
to create more platforms it's logic so
starting from the next video we are
going to prepare everything to start
creating our level parts and then we are
of course going to start encoding all of
that so that we can have our level to
play the game if something was not clear
in regards to this video make sure that
you ask in the comment down below and i
will help you out and i will see you
guys in the next video alrighty then my
game dev elves before we can create our
level we also need to create the
obstacles because they are going to be
part of the level so over here in our c
plus class i am going to create a new c
plus plus class and it is going to
inherit from the actor so one is going
to be called obstacle so over here i'm
going to say
obstacle
and of course wait for unreal engine to
add it into the project again that ssd
is going to arrive on mondays or
thursday tuesday because now it's
saturday for me recording this i'm going
to sync to you in the meantime
thank you very much that will be five
dollars extra
now the bad news is that we need to
create another one so right click over
here new c plus plus class and this time
an actor again and this one is going to
be spike so spikes there you go hit
enter of course and wait for it to
torture us what else can i say the good
thing is that we are not going to code
anything instead we are just going to
use these classes so that we can you
know do a cast later on when we collide
with these objects of course from the
blueprints that we will create so over
here if i open it let me just reload
everything reload again
there you go so we have the spikes we
have the obstacle but as i said we are
not going to code anything over here
instead we're just going to use these as
references to create blueprints so let's
go back in our unreal engine and over
here into the blueprints i'm going to
right click a new folder and i'm going
to call this one obstacles
and inside of the obstacles i'm going to
create a blueprint class one is going to
inherit from the obstacle which is this
bad boy and i'm going to call it bp
obstacle
simple very simple right click again
blueprint class and over here one is
going to inherit from the spikes and i'm
going to call it bp underscore spikes
simple double click it open it in our
editor over here almost said visual
studio but it's actually the editor
again
so what are we going to do well first
things first for the spikes i am going
to click on this bp spikes and add a
static mesh component that i'm simply
going to call spike very simple now for
the spike static mesh over here i'm
going to click on the drop down list and
filter for our quad pyramid so i'm going
to say quad pyramid there you go this is
the one that we want and over here for
the materials i am going to filter for
the clay new and this is the one that we
want there you go
this is pretty much it except over here
i'm going to set it to minus 50
on the z position so simple as that and
also when it comes to the collision we
are going to do one interesting thing
first things first i'm going to compile
and save this and i'm going to go here
into the project settings and i'm going
to go here into the collision for the
project settings so it's basically this
over here under engine when you go into
the project settings over here we can
create our own object channels
what does that mean that basically means
we can create our own layers to
differentiate the collision between
actors so over here i'm going to click
on new object channel and the name for
that one is going to be
obstacle
and the obstacle is going to block so
the obstacle is simply going to block
the player it's basically going to be a
solid body not allowing the player to
pass through and that is what a block is
and i'm going to click here accept next
over here i'm going to say new object
channel and this one is going to be our
spike but the spike is going to overlap
the spike is going to overlap so that we
can overlap in the tech collision
between the spike and the player i'm
going to click here accept so now we
have the block and the overlap channels
over here what does that mean that means
now that i can go inside of the spikes
over here and scroll down over here
where it says the collision there you go
this bad boy over here i can zoom in for
you to see there you go
so over here the collision preset
i'm going to set that to custom so click
on the drop down list and click here
custom from the list
over here we are going to have the
collision
back to query only so we're going to
have query only no physics collision
because we don't want the physics we
don't want to collide as a physics
object with our pyramid or basically the
spike and over here for the object type
now we are going to have so let me just
compile and save this so now we should
see the spike and the obstacle which is
the one that we have just created over
here if you don't see it right away just
compile and save for your blueprint and
then here from the object type where it
says world dynamic you can select this
one to be spike and there you go so over
here i'm going to set our
spike to overlap everything
except over here the obstacle i don't
want it to overlap the obstacle and we
can also set here not to overlap or
simply ignore the camera because we
don't need the camera compile and save
that so it is going to overlap all of
these other responses such as the pawn
physics body which basically our player
we're going to set him to be upon so
this right here will be able to overlap
with the player and of course then we
will detect collision between them and
destroy the player and all of that good
stuff
so now we can move forward to our cube
or to the obstacle which is this one and
again from here static component we are
going to filter for our static mesh
and i'm going to call this one cube or
simply call it block obstacle there you
go over here for the static mesh i am
going to filter for the cube so simply
type cube and there you go where is the
qbqb there you go here is the cubie
cubie and over here for the material i'm
going to say basic shape material this
is what i want compile and save that now
i'm going to leave it 0 0 0 for x y and
z and i'm not going to touch the
rotation i mean there is no point in
touching the rotation because it will
still be the same it's a cube and going
back over here again for the collision
preset instead of block all dynamic we
are going to set it to custom over here
the collision enabled will be query and
physics because again this obstacle this
block obstacle it is going to be a solid
body
and it is going to block the player when
the player collides with it the player
will not be able to pass through it and
over here for the object type we are
going to set that to be an obstacle
and we are going to set it to block
everything except over here the spike we
don't need it to block the spike you can
simply overlap the spike but it is going
to block everything meaning it's a solid
body i am simply going to compile and
save that and there you go
so this is pretty much it as a
preparation when it comes to creating
our level parts now of course if
something was not clear make sure that
you ask in the comment down below and
starting from the next video we are
going to build our level parts and the
level and all of the good stuff then we
are going to start spawning them and
yada yada yada so i will see you guys in
the next video what it is game dev
against we're in the hose moving forward
now we are going to create our levels
and for that we are going to go inside
of our c plus classes and right click
and build a base level class which is
going to inherit from the actor and i'm
going to call this one so over here
base
level and hit enter to create the class
and of course we will have to wait a
moment or two or a gazillion moments for
unreal engine to take mercy upon our
motors mortal souls
until we wait for that ssd man the more
you watch these videos the more ad
revenue i get i guess and the more
faster i can buy that ssd
just kidding but let's go over here and
reload everything there you go here we
have our base level dot h and here we
have our base level dot cbp
so inside of our dot h the first thing
here at the top right below the includes
over here i'm going to forward declare
so i'm going to say class u box
component as i said this is called
forward declaration so that we don't
have to use the import or include excuse
me now going back here at the bottom
right below the public virtual void i'm
going to create protected and i am going
to create a new property
and this your property is going to be
blueprint read and write it is also
going to be editable anywhere so edit
anywhere and last but not least i'm
going to set it under a category which
is going to be equal to triggers like
that what the hell is this teacher i
don't know i'm confused i i want to slap
you listen listen and don't slap me okay
so what we have over here is blueprint
read and write basically meaning the
component that we now declare which is
going to be a ubox component which is a
pointer so i need to add a star over
here and i need to call this or i don't
need but i'm going to call it a trigger
which means that this component trigger
can be read and written
we can edit it and we can get a value of
it inside of the blueprint edit anywhere
means we can edit it inside of the
blueprint editor
on the side in the details tab and the
category triggers basically when we
search for this component
in the blueprint code we will find it
under the triggers category
so we can also call it my triggers you
can call it like that and we will see
that when we search for it so what i'm
going to do is copy this and paste it
down below because we are going to have
the same signature but this time we're
not going to call this one trigger but
i'm going to call it spawn location like
that
and last but not least we're going to
have two public functions so public like
that
and what's going to happen here these
functions are going to return a ubox
component which is a pointer so this one
is going to be get
trigger which is going to get our
trigger not tigger it's trigger
and another one for you box component
and it is a pointer so here i'm going to
say get spawn location like that and
there you go now don't worry if this is
still white text you know it takes
unreal under engine for this to compile
while we're waiting for that ssd you get
my point i'm going to right click on
this bad boy quick actions and
refactoring i'm going to create a
declaration for it over here do the same
thing quick actions refactoring create a
declaration for it and of
course i
i don't know what to say i mean you see
you see the issues we all have
so inside of our cpp is where we are
going to include
same as what we do with our players so
include and i'm going to include
components
backslash box component.h
it's dot h there you go
and inside of our beginplay
i am first going to test if the trigger
if it's not equal to null ptr meaning
null pointer then i'm going to say
trigger and from here i'm going to say b
hidden in game is going to be equal to
true and not allow that trigger to be
you know visible in the game let me just
compile all of this so that we make sure
that nothing is wrong and that
everything should be working because
it's not giving me autocomplete it's not
giving you anything you see build
succeeded we're good to go but you know
it takes unreal engine i will probably
have to restart or close my visual
studio and open it for this to work i
don't know do not ask me over here we're
not going to return an old pointer
instead i'm going to return a trigger
and over here i'm not going to return on
all pointers that i'm going to return a
spawn location that's all there is to it
and again make sure that you compiled or
built this so it's ctrl shift b to build
this code and voila there you go of
course another way to build this code is
to go here and simply click compile is
the same exact thing but i am not going
to do that otherwise we will wait a lot
so let's go over here inside of our
blueprints and right click and create a
new folder and this one is going to be
our levels inside of the levels folder
i'm going to right click and create a
blueprint class and inherit from the
base level there you go and select i'm
going to call this on bp level 1. of
course we're going to have level 2 up to
level ten and what's going to happen in
this one i'm going to open it and i'm
going to create a few levels
and then i'm going to leave up to you to
create the other levels because you know
this process can be a little bit tedious
it takes a little bit of time and all of
the good stuff the first thing that i'm
going to do over here
inside of the
inside of the bp level i'm going to go
and add a few components the first few
are going to be a static mesh one is
going to be a floor
and another one i'm going to duplicate
this bad boy so copy and paste and
instead of floor i'm going to call this
one cube
there you go
and also i'm going to have two box
triggers so box collision that is one i
am going to call and this is not going
to be a child of the cube so i am going
to call this one
trigger box
copy and paste it and this one i am
going to call it spawn location box let
me just compile and save that and let me
just add everything that i need and we
are going to code or
actually before that in the event graph
what i'm going to do is remove all of
this
and over here
we have in the event begin play
i'm going to set the spawn location so
i'm going to right click over here and
i'm going to say set
spawn location and notice it's under my
triggers look at that you see this over
here
look at that my triggers it's basically
what we did in our code so if i go back
over here where we have declared these
triggers look at that so my triggers
this is that category so now we can find
them under this category inside of our
blueprints when we want to code so i'm
going to right click and i'm going to
say set spawn location
and the spawn location again make sure
that it is under my trigger so set spawn
location here it is under my triggers
and the execution flow is going to go
over here and i'm going to set that
or the spawn location box is going to be
the spawn location next from there i'm
going to say set trigger
and it's this one over here under
my triggers
so the execution flow is going to
continue over here and then i'm going to
take the trigger box and plug it in over
here and let me just compile and save
that what this is going to do is going
to set the spawn location from our code
to this one over here so we have you
know connected these two meaning that
now
this is a reference to this over here
same thing that we did over here make
sure that you compile and save that so
now going inside of our viewports and
here is my floor what am i going to do
to the floor well i'm not going to do
anything to the floor because you know
i'm a good boy i'm not going to do
anything
instead what i'm going to do is go over
here for the static mesh and filter for
the cube
and there you go here is our cube for
the material we are going to say basic
shape material voila
that's all there is to it and i am going
to change the scale of it so the scale x
is going to be 10
the scale
y
is going to be 1 and r let me just go
over here i have locked the icon so i
don't want to lock anything but over
here scale x is going to be 10 y is 1
and z is 0.5 so this is going to be
this is going to be our floor
next we're going to have a cube so over
here taking the cube
and again adding a cube to it and over
here basic shape basic
shape material there you go
now for this cube i'm going to set it
and 90 for the z position and leave it
like that and that's all there is to it
the trigger box i'm going to take it and
for the trigger box i'm going to set
that location 380.
the location was going to be stay or
stay at 0 and the location z250
and i am also going to set the z scale
to 10 over here for the
trigger box the trigger box is basically
going to be the trigger that when we
pass through it then we are going to
detect collision and then we are going
to spawn a new level so this is what
we're going to do with the trigger box
so when the player passes here and he
touches that collision
then we are going to then we are going
to detect that and we are going to spawn
new level and over here just make sure
that it is overlap all dynamics so the
collision preset is set to that
next we have the spawn location and the
spawn location what am i going to do
with it is simply i am going to
reposition it so i'm going to position
it at 1000
and that's all there is to it so the
spawn location we are going to use its
position to position the next level so
when we spawn a new level it is going to
start positioning from here and
basically it's going to form a new level
like that
simple that's all what we are going to
do with the spawn or with the spawn
location
so this is our level one and just make
sure that you compile and save that if i
go over here inside of the gameplay i'm
going to right click and create a new
blueprint class and now you're going to
assume that again i'm going to use the
base level but this time no instead i'm
going to use level one and every next
level that i create is going to be
a child of level one so bp level one i'm
going to select that and this one's
going to be bp level two there you go
and i'm simply going to open it it
already has all of these components set
up in the event graph it is going to
call the parents begin play which is
going to do all of this it's going to
prepare everything we don't have to do
it again for this blueprint
very clever i know
and that's all there is to it of course
now we're simply going to add new things
to it and
that would be it for example the cube
that we have over here i'm going to
reposition it so the x position is going
to be minus 330
the y is going to stay the same and the
z is going to stay the same but i'm also
going to add new boxes so i'm going to
copy this cube and paste it and i'm
going to call this one cube2
and for this cube2 i am going to
reposition it so x is going to be 190
y 0 z 130 and i am going to set the z
scale at 3
for the z scale
simple as that and copy this one copy
and paste now we have the cube 3 and for
the cube 3
the position x is minus 70 the position
y 0 180 for the z
and set the
z scale to 0.3
and voila compile and save that so this
is our level two blueprint
simple very very simple going back over
here right clicking and again blueprint
class again inheriting from level one
there you go not level two but level one
and this one is going to be bp level
three
again we have everything prepared we we
have our base cube we have everything
here prepared in the event graph we
don't have to do anything but we are
going to change or reposition this cube
so again minus 3 3 0 for the x
y i'm not going to touch in z i'm not
going to touch so it's going to stay as
is but now i'm going to copy this cube
and
rename it to cube 2
and this cube 2 is going to be
repositioned
at 70 for the x
y 0 4 20 on the z axis and over here i'm
going to say 3 scale for the z compile
and save that
moving forward we are going to have
another level so blueprint class over
here inherit from the level
so inherit from our level one
select bp level four
double click it and open it over here in
visual studio
and again
simply repositioning things so cube over
here is going to be repositioned x is
minus 303 30 excuse me
174 the z-axis then i'm going to copy
this cube and rename it to cube 2.
for r cube 2 i am going to set the
position 160 on x y 0 20 20 or
2 2 0 for the z
and resize the z scale to 4. last but
not least we have another cube so copy
and paste and this one is going to be at
10 for the x 370 on the z
and the scale z is going to stay one but
the scale x is going to be two
and compile and save that this is our
level four moving forward i'm going to
right click
and again inherit from level one
there you go
and this one's going to be our bp
level five and now we're going to add
some spikes in here and this is the last
level that i'm going to create the next
levels are on you
so over here for the cube i'm going to
set the x at -30 and the
z
390 and i am going to set the x scale to
3 the z scale to 0.3 there you go
and last but not least we are going to
attach something or we are going to
attach a spike
and i am going to do the following so
here i am going to click on add
component
selecting the bp level and i'm going to
filter for child actor
and this one is going to be our spike
there you go i'm going to call this on
spike 2 but of course we're going to
have spike 1 as well so copy this one
and
so what we are going to do for our spike
two is over here you see the child actor
component from here we can select the
blueprint we can click here and i can
filter for spikes
there you go and let me just remove this
one i'm going to duplicate this one
after
so for this one i'm going to set the x
to 2 to 0 and the z is 40. there you go
but i am going to move it a little bit
upwards so something like this
there you go here on this position grid
snap valve i'm going to set it to one so
i can snap a little bit better
voila there you go and i'm simply going
to copy this and paste it and this one's
going to be our spike
one and simply move it over here
basically the position x is minus 260
and there you go compile and save that
so this is the last level i'm going to
create i'm going to cut out the video
right now and create the other levels
and go back and show you the levels that
i have created but you have plenty of
info for you to create your own levels
a quick note you don't have to create
the same levels as i did you can create
you can create levels on your own which
is a good practice and i encourage that
every single time
so again for these spikes when we you
know touch them we're going to die but
we will see that later on do not worry
about that right now
and basically that's it every single
level that you create is going to
inherit from level one i'm going to cut
out the video right now and i'm going to
continue just remember when you add
spikes you're going to add them as child
actor components so from here you're
going to filter for the child actor when
you select the child actor over here
you're going to select the spikes for
that child actor and that would be it
that would be basically it
so
i don't have any of the angst
at any angst i don't have anything else
clever to say i don't know how to talk i
will see in a few when i create the
other level parts and i am back did you
miss me because it took me a while to
create all this of course for you it was
a few moments but you know if you didn't
miss me then you cannot watch this video
anymore uh i'm just kidding anyways here
we have the level six seven eight nine
and ten so this is my level six as you
can see you can also download the
complete project i have provided that
under the you know importing or creating
the project video you can you know
download the assets
or basically the complete project as
well and see that on your own or you can
create your own levels which i highly
encourage you to do but basically this
is my level six as you can see so we
have a cube here and two spikes next we
have the level seven which is very
simple as you can see i'm not even
moving the collision box or the trigger
box and the spawn position they're
staying at the same spot where they are
in level one and i'm just you know
moving the cube resizing it adding here
child actors which are the spikes over
here i have the level eight as you can
see this is my level eight one two three
there you go so three boxes or t three
cubes that is level nine there you go we
have a spike in this weird thing over
here the l shape if your name is lauren
then you know this is for you lauren and
over here we have the level 10 there you
go and that's all there is to it compile
and save i cannot say anything else or i
don't have anything else clever to say
except if something is not clear make
sure that you ask in the comment down
below
and uh yeah i will see you in the next
video you know where else can i see you
you know i don't live where you live i
don't know you in person so i cannot see
you you know in your home i can see in
the next video so again if something's
not clear ask down below i'll see you in
next video alrighty then my game dev
elves let's go here in the c plus plus
class i'm going to right click and
create a new c plus plus class inherit
from the actor and this one is going to
be my spawn level so spawn level or
level spawner however you want to name
it i do not care you can name it carl
you can name it
same name as your grandma that is up to
you i cannot control you okay i name it
spawn level and this is going to be the
class that is going to allow us to spawn
all of these levels but before we
actually can do that we of course need
to add a few things inside of that class
but first things first you know the ssd
drive is still not there i think i will
finish this recording
today which is saturday for me i don't
know which day it is for you and there
you go
some info that we don't need so here we
have the spawn level cpp and
spawnlevel.h so what's going to happen
in the spawnlevel.h first things first
here above below that includes i am
going to add my a baselevel class
because we are going to have levels that
we are going to put inside of this
inside of the
spawn level so over here
i am going to create another public like
this i know it's right below the public
but this is how i differentiate my own
variables i like to group them and
that's all there is to it so over here
i'm going to create a u function like
that and this is going to be my void
spawn level which is going to take a
boolean is first
meaning is this the first level that we
are going to spawn we are also going to
have our own on begin overlap so i'm
going to go here inside of our player
character and simply grab it from here
so that i don't have to write all of
these parameters and all of that stuff
you get the point it can be a little bit
tedious it can be a little bit you know
whatever so there you go so just go from
the player and grab it copy and paste it
it's the same signature the same name
and everything next over here we're
going to have protected and for the
protected we are going to first have a
player who is a pawn and it's a pointer
and i'm going to call him player we are
going to get a reference to the player
next over here i'm going to create a you
property
you property which is going to be edit
anywhere
so we will be able to edit it from the
blueprint itself and it's going to be a
t
sub class of a
base level and it's going to be our
level one and this is the reason why i
have imported this over here so don't
worry if you don't have those
autocompletes i mean i don't have them
as you can see the reason for that is
simple because unreal engine is slow in
you know
reading all of this and the ssd drive is
still not here so over here we have the
level two and we have the level three
comma level four come on level five you
can see you know some
not everything about the game dev is you
know fun and all of that stuff some
things are a little bit tedious for you
and me to do but hey you signed up for
this i did not you know
i didn't
threaten you or whatever didn't force
you so this is all on you next we are
going to have a t array or simply an
array of a base level who are pointers
and is going to be my level list and
last but not least we are going to have
also public variables one is going to be
random level because we are going to
randomize the spawning of the level
we are also going to have an f
vector which is going to be our spawn
location for the level and i'm going to
call here f vector simply like that
we're also going to have the f rotator
and this is going to be our spawn
rotation again f rotate or simply
declare it over here and our f actor
spawn parameters which is going to be
our spawn info was going to be equal to
again simply copy this over here so that
i can declare it because these are the
variables that we are going to use over
and over and ctrl shift to build this
bad boy because you know
i need to build it okay
and uh yeah that will be it let us wait
for it a moment or two
and there you go we have something over
here i believe function public study
void expect struck oh okay okay okay
i didn't actually
you know declare these two so right
click quick actions and refactoring
create the definition
simple
right click actions and refactoring
create the definition again very simple
but yet
you know people are forgettable they
tend to forget things as you just saw
that i cannot wait for that ssd to
arrive man it's like you know i'm
waiting for a new life like i died and
i'm and i'm waiting to live again so yep
i'm going to sing to you let me take my
ukulele
i don't have a ukulele i don't know what
that is i just heard that word
and i told you that okay so over here
let me just now compile this
and you see only now
we see you know different colors of
everything that we have declared and
stuff like that but now the you know
completion or the build has succeeded
there you go
so now inside of the spawn level we are
going to include or add our includes so
we are going to have over here include
baselevel.h so that is one of the
includes the next include is going to be
our engine.h
so we're going to use the whole engine
and the last include is going to be our
components
box component dot h like that there you
go and i don't know why it's giving me
here a red because you know it's
included it's the same thing so what do
we need to create
here
inside of our spawn level
is where the main thing the main magic
is going to happen so over here what i'm
going to do i'm going to say spawn
location is going to be equal to f
vector
and over here i'm going to say 0.0 f 1
000 for the y and 0.0 f for the z
why a thousand well because a thousand
units is or thousand centimeters is how
large the level is because we you know
set the level to be 10 scale on the
x-axis i believe i think it was x-axis i
cannot remember but anyways it's 1000
units which means that when we have one
level over here if we want to place
another level over here that's 1000
units
that's all there is to it
next we have the spawn rotation which is
going to be equal to f rotator and it is
going to be 0 here 90 here and 0 here so
on the y where simply and rotate
like that so 90 on the y and there you
go
what i'm also going to check over here
or perform a check if this is not the
first time we're spawning so if not is
first
which is basically the parameter that we
are going to pass here when we spawn the
first
level we are going to say this is true
but for all other levels this is not
going to be true so if it's not the
first level then i'm going to say here a
base level which is a pointer last level
i'm going to get the last level i'm
going to say level list
and dot last and this is from the array
of the level list where i'm going to get
the last level and the reason for that
is because now i'm going to say spawn
location so spawn location is going to
be equal to
last level
and from here i'm going to say get spawn
location and from there i'm going to get
the component transform component
transform and from there i'm going to
say dot get translation
there you go
and
if i
can finish the statement if i hover over
it says returns the translation
of the component basically it will
return the position of our spawn
location and notice here i'm using get
spawn location if you remember in a base
level over here we're getting the spawn
location by returning it look at that
gatspawn location we're returning the
spawn location and if you double
remember inside of the blueprint for
that so if i go over here inside of the
blueprints and the level and over here
we're setting the spawn location to be
equal to this one which is this bad boy
over here and this is that spawn
location
so we are going to get that value that
reference here and from there we are
going to know where is the last position
of the last level so next over here i'm
going to randomize this i'm going to say
a random level is going to be equal to f
math
column colon and i'm going to use a rand
range between 1 and 10 which is going to
return numbers between 1 and 10
including both of these and then i'm
going to say a base level which is a
pointer
new level
by default it's going to be equal to
null ptr so null pointer but now i am
going to test for the random level so if
our random level is equal to 1 like that
then i'm going to say new level
which is the one that we have just
created over here that is going to be
equal to get the world
and from the world i'm going to spawn an
actor
which is a type of base level so this is
going to be the actor that we're going
to spawn and we're going to spawn the
level 1 actor at the spawn location
using the spawn rotation
throwing bars at the mars and and over
here we're going to use the spawn info
so spawn info
like that there you go
and simply now i can copy this and i can
say here else
and paste this over here if the random
level is equal to two then over here i'm
simply going to spawn level two that's
all there is to it we need to re and we
need to why am i saying
we need to repeat this process so again
this one is three now over here we need
to spawn the level three
going back over here as i said sometimes
things can get tedious over here random
level four over here random level four
of course we can do this you know
i mean we need to do it i don't know
what i wanted to say anyways six now and
over here
there you go six
over here now
come on
we're going to have seven
seven
eight nine and ten and we're done so
don't don't cry don't be a cry baby and
and all of that stuff be patient
imagine how how i felt when i created
all of this you know so
yeah there you go the last one is here
and finally we are done so 10 over here
spawning the 10 over here so based on
the as you can see based on the random
level that we have over here then we are
going to as i said this is going to
return either one or 10 or numbers in
between so based on those numbers then
we are going to set the new level which
is currently at null pointer to be equal
to one of these levels if it's one then
level one then two then three you get
the point but if something is not clear
make sure you ask in the comment down
below over here what i'm going to do if
we have a new level we need to perform
this test because otherwise
if if this gets to an old pointer but of
course there is no chance that this will
get to an old pointer because over here
where you know the randomized numbers
are from one to ten and we're testing
for all of them
but if we have a level
then we are going to say if
new level and from here i'm going to get
the trigger so i'm going to get the
trigger from the new level again what is
this new trigger if or getting the
trigger if you remember from the base
level over here we're getting the
trigger we're returning that
the trigger is again
the huge box over here this is the
trigger where the player needs to pass
by so if the player passes by this
trigger
then we are going to spawn
new levels
simple as that very very simple so if i
go back
over here
so if we can get the trigger then we're
going to say new
level and from there get the trigger and
from the trigger we're going to say on
component begin overlap
dot now we're going to add the dynamic
which is basically we're going to assign
a function that will be executed when we
begin that overlap so over here i'm
going to say this and from here i am
simply going to copy this
and i'm going to say and and paste this
over here so essentially when we collide
with the trigger of the level the one
that i showed you a moment ago we are
going to
call the on overlap again from over here
from the spawn level and over here what
we are going to do is we are going to
call spawn level
passing false to spawn a new level
simple as that so it's going to pass or
go through all of this over here same as
what we did right now go through it and
then it is simply going to spawn a new
level and basically that's all there is
to it that's pretty much all there is to
it nothing you know more
and over here inside of our on begin
play we need to
spawn the level so spawn level and over
here i'm going to say true but i'm going
to copy this because the first one is
going to be true and the
next
three are going to be false over here
false let me just copy paste copy paste
let me just compile this and make sure
that we don't have any problems any
issues because you know
this is coding i am you know i cannot
code according to some of the comments
so it can happen that i missed something
and all of that good stuff so
essentially over here in the and while
this is compiling i'm going to try and
explain
what is going on
so over here we have created a spawn
level
function that is going to spawn new
levels we have the spawn location we
have the spawn rotation
and over here if it's not the first
because when we spawn the first one
we're going to say it's true but for all
others it's going to be false so if it's
not the first level platform that is
going to be spawned then we are going to
get the last level inside of our level
array and we of course need to add
which is one thing that we need to do at
the end so we need to add our level to
the level list so we're going to get the
last level from the level list and then
we're going to get its location of the
spawn location which is the component
that we added so we're going to get its
location and know from where we should
spawn the next level over here we're
going to randomize the values so
from 1 to 10 and if that random value is
equal to 1 we're going to spawn level 1
if it's 2 level 2
and so on up to level 10. over here as i
said i did forget so if we have new
level after that so we're going to
attach a dynamic and what the hell is
this again when i save you see it's
saving because it's processing
everything all of this here
so again if we have a new level and we
do all of this over here so we get the
trigger from the level we attach the on
component begin overlap we add that to
the dynamic spawn level and all of that
good stuff then over here i'm going to
say level list dot add
and i am going to and over here it's
actually level list like that and
capital a and i'm going to add the new
level so new level there you go
but i am not going to allow to have more
than five elements inside of the level
list so over here i'm going to test if
our level list
dot num so if the length or how many
elements we have in that level list is
more than five then from there i'm going
to say level list dot remove at and i'm
going to remove the last element inside
of that level list
now the bad news is that this still did
not compile and even more worse news is
that we need to compile it again
so i am probably going to
cut out the video right here until the
ssd drive arrives
and i'm going to continue from the you
know when this compiles but again here
at the end what we did is we added the
new level to the level list so that we
you know next time when we try to get
the last level we will actually have it
so we will not have an empty list but we
will have a level inside of that list
and we are checking if the elements or
how many elements are inside of that
level list if that
number exceeds five then we're going to
remove the element that's at index 0
meaning the first level that's there so
that's all there is to it and i will see
you in a few when this compiles and i am
back we have a problem over here that is
the reason why this was yelling at me so
here spawn rotation i do need to declare
this as spawn rotation and all here for
every single level i need to add that to
spawn rotation so
spawn location here spawn rotation there
you go here it's spawn rotation
rotation rotation
stupid misspelling i really cannot wait
for that ssd drive to arrive you know
i'm saying this ssd drive over and over
again in hopes that some of you guys
will send it to me but you know
apparently nothing will come out of it
so i need to rebuild this again but this
time i think it will be faster because
it rebuilded it once so it you know went
through that whole process and you know
it now knows and it can go faster
because we for sure waited a little bit
well
a little more bit for all of this to
reload anyways
come on let us wait and now there you go
build has succeeded finally finally
finally if something was not clear in
regards to this one and i've explained
it two times make sure that you ask in
the comment down below because now we
need to move on and go here inside of
our blueprints and right click
and create our level spawner which who
is going to you know inherit from the
level or spawn level so spawn
level there you go
from here i need to say bp spawn level
and go inside and attach all of these
levels so we need to attach all of these
levels so from here we need to take
level one then level two
then here we have level three and all of
that good stuff so
the tedious part that nobody likes to do
but everybody likes to play the game so
eight and nine
and last but not least here is our level
10 and we need to compile and save that
so now i can go here in the game plan i
can simply put my level spawner i can
put him here zero zero zero it does not
matter what matters is if i hit the play
button that he will spawn the levels and
indeed he did there you go look at that
all of the levels i can possess the
character and now i can run
and every single time we you know pass
the trigger we will spawn new levels as
you can see over here we have infinite
number of levels and every single time
you see they're differentiated look at
that and i can run and all of the good
stuff and yada yada you get the point so
there you go
as you can see we can run infinitely
so the last step is to add our
wall that is chasing us that is going to
kill us that we need to
and there you go for whatever reason why
these levels
hmm
this was for the i need to redo the
level or recheck this level that has
these two
i probably need to reposition the oh
actually no i don't need to reposition
but i need to
make that trigger a little bit larger
because we jumped over it and that is
the reason why that is the reason why we
did not have new levels so we need to
make sure that trigger is a little bit
larger because again here is the level
you see we just need to make sure that
the trigger is larger on every single
level that is so make sure
and since we are inheriting from the
level one we can i believe go simply
over here inside of the levels level one
there you go and make this over here the
trigger box a little bit larger so i
don't know let's say 20 something like
that so it will not allow it and we can
move it
there you go so now the player has no
chance
five to five is going to be the position
for it even five three zero five three
zero
and compile and save that and i believe
it will change it for every single level
yes it will there you go it will change
it for every single level
so
as i said now the player will not be
able to jump over it and it will not
give us the problem that we just had of
not having the level so now even if i go
from here and i try to jump way over
here i'm still going to create new
levels there you go
so if something was not clear in regards
to this video just ask i will not answer
and just kidding i will answer and help
you out and that would be it for this
video i will see you guys in the next
one where we're going to create our wall
that is going to start to chase us and
all of that stuff and then we are going
to wrap up our game see you then all
righty then my gamedev gankstar roni o's
let us wrap up our game so going here
inside of our c plus plus classes are
going to create a new c plus plus class
but this one is going to inherit from
the spikes so i'm going to click here
show all classes and filter for our
spikes
it's it's not spikes spike just it's
spikes there you go
and this one is going to be our wall
spike there you go
and what's gonna happen inside of this
class is i am not going to do basically
anything in the dot h file but of course
we need to you know go through the
painful process of all of this
man send me that ssd what else can i say
i'm waiting for it just kidding in a few
days it will come the in the next
tutorial will be ready and this is going
to be fast as as as a
as something that is fast i don't know a
squirrel so in the wall let's go over
here reload everything first while
spike.h i'm not going to do anything but
in the dot cpp file we are going to do
something so over here basically in the
dot h file we are going to have all of
the you know
basics so we have the generated body
we're going to have a public over here
we're going to have a
wall spike which is our constructor in
the protected so protected
we are going to have our virtual void so
virtual
void begin play because we want to
override it so override in our public
we're going to have our
so from here it's going to be virtual
void tick and it's going to be float
delta time
and over here override there you go
because now in the dot cpp file we are
going to implement all of that so over
here
we are going to say a wall spike column
colon and it's going to be our awol
spike basically the constructor
and over here we're going to have our
primary
actor
tick dot b
can
ever tick is equal to true so we're
going to enable that
also over here in our void a wall spike
column column is going to be our begin
so it's begin
play
what's going to happen over here first
you are going to call the super which is
the super class and call the begin play
from there so begin
play
there you go
actually begin play like this and then
from here what i'm going to do is it's
not being it's begin play
like that begin play
i'm going to say this and i'm going to
get the root component from our
blueprint and i'm going to say component
so component velocity and i'm going to
set that to f vector
0 for the x 25 for the y and 0 for the z
so this is the velocity or basically the
speed of r of the actor and next i'm
going to say voit a will spike with
double or capital w spike column call on
tick
and over here we're going to have the
delta
time like that
so what's gonna happen over here again
first i'm going to call the super tick
so super
tick which is going to take the delta
time and i know you're expecting me to
do some jokes so you're tick look i'm
not danny i'm not trying to be danny i
don't care you know i'm not going to do
the tick joke and what not set actor
location and from here
i am going to get the actor location
which is the current location of this
actor and i'm going to add to it
an f vector
and inside of this f vector i'm going to
say 0 for dex
3
50 for the y
multiplied with delta time delta time
so
it's delta time there you go and zero
for the z and over here i'm going to say
true and that's all there is to it so
let me just compile this and we can make
sure that everything is okay we don't
have any issues essentially what we did
over here is inside of on beginplay
there we go succeeded we're good in on
beginplay we set the component velocity
of the root component to be 25 on the y
and then over here inside of the tick we
are moving the actor by using its
current location and adding to it
only the y here because x and z are zero
that means they will not move and we're
adding to it 350 multiply with delta
time of course you can set a public
variable speed or something like that
that is you know up to you if you want
to do that i'm not going to do it but
yeah there you go so let's go inside of
the editor
and inside of the blueprints that i'm
going to go in the obstacles and right
click and create a wall obstacle so i'm
going to say wall spike because it is
going to inherit from the wall spike bp
wall spike and we need to edit this we
need to edit it to look like a wall so
over here i am going to filter for the
static mesh that
i'm going to call wall simply
over here for the static mesh which is
going to be our cube i'm going to say
cube like that
there you go
and here basic
shape
material voila
i'm going to change you know the scale
so the y and the z scale are going to be
10
this is it over here for our presets you
see it's set to block all dynamic
instead over here i'm going to say no
collision now the reason for that is
because
i'm going to detect collision with a box
collider so i'm going to here go here
and i'm going to say by collision
and simply call it box you can call it
box or however
and for this one i am going to set the x
scale at 3 y scale is going to be 20 and
the z scale is going to be 20 and with
this one i want to detect collision with
our player and in order for me to do
that i'm going to scroll down over here
where it says for the collision presets
and i am going to set this one to the
custom collision over here i'm going to
say query only no physics collision so
basically no physics collision over here
for the world dynamic i'm actually going
to set this to spike because the spike
will be able to collide with the player
compile and save that now in order for
us or for this to work we are going to
go in our player which is this one let
me just close these levels
so closing
all of the levels come on there you go
for the player i'm going to select his
capsule component and scroll down over
here for the collision preset it is set
to be a custom one and it is set to be a
pawn so this is what we need to do with
it so set it to be a custom one set it
to be a pawn make sure that it is
overlapping the spike because that is
what we need so we need it to overlap
the spike
now what we need to do is go over here
inside of our game and we are going to
add our wall spike here he is and let me
just reposition him
so the x position is going to be minus
30.
the y is going to be minus 830
and the z it's 4
5 5. and of course i'm also going to
rotate it 90 degrees
on the so 90 degrees on the z-axis if i
hit the play button now there you go you
see it is going it is trying to search
for us or actually trying to get us if
it catches us look at now it's simply
going to pass through us we're not
detecting collision in the code this is
why we don't see anything so we need to
detect collision in the code for
anything to happen but the point that i
wanted to show you is that it is not
detecting
it is not
a solid object it simply passes through
so how can we detect collision with the
player i don't want to leave that in the
next video instead i'm going to do it
right now i can't leave it in the next
video but i'm going to do it right now
so going back over here inside of our
runner character cpp at the top here so
inside of begin play after or before we
set can move to be true we need to get
the capsule component so we need to say
get capsule component which is the
component the capsule component of the
player that we have just edited you know
the one that i set it it needs to be
upon
so from there i'm going to see on
component begin overlap dot and i'm
going to say add dynamic and over here
we're going to add this and i'm simply
going to go down and copy the name over
here so that we don't have to you know
type it out so and and that there you go
so this is going to take that capsule
component from the player which is you
know in the blueprint so taking that
capsule component
then it is going to attach to it our on
begin overlap or on overlap begin so
essentially what's going to happen
inside of this one is that we are going
to detect if we have collided with a
spike or a wall spike so over here i'm
going to say if the other
actor is not equal to null ptr
so
it's ptr not tpr it's ptr
other actor is basically the actor the
other one that we have collided with
inside of our game so if it's not equal
to null we have collided with some of
the actors then we're going to say a
spike like that or spikes which is a
pointer and i'm going to say here wall
spikes there you go or wall spike and
that is going to be equal to i'm going
to cast that to a wall spike like that
and i'm casting the
other
actor now we don't have the completion
or anything because we do need to go
here on top
and right here we need to include a few
things so we need to say include our
spikes dot h file
we also need to include our wall spike
dot h file and last but not least we
need to include the engine
so it's engine.h because we are going to
restart the game when the player dies in
order for us to do that then we need to
use the engine and there you go over
here our spikes wall spike we're going
to do that or try to cast it next i'm
going to say a spikes and over here
because it's a pointer
spike and i'm going to cast it into an a
spike like that and i'm casting again
the other actor same as what i did b4
and actually here it spikes not spike
so essentially if we collide
with either the wall so if wall
spike
or we have the spike so if we collide
with any of these meaning they are not
null so essentially over here what we
are trying to do we are casting the
other actor to the wall spike and other
actor to the spike spike basically so
below over here we we're testing if we
have a wall spike or if we have a spike
meaning they are not equal to null that
means we collided with one of the two
that means game over
so now i'm going to say get mesh which
is going to get the mesh of our
character and then i'm going to
deactivate that mesh i'm also going to
say get mesh
and from here i am going to say set
visibility for that mesh to be false so
that we don't see it anymore in the game
can move
is now equal to false we cannot move
anymore
and next we are going to reload the
level
after two seconds and for that we need
to create f timer handle i'm going to
say unused so unused
handle like that
and i'm going to say get world timer
manager
and from there i'm going to say set
timer
and i'm going to pass the unused handle
so
unused handle
into this and then i am going to pass
this function which is our runner
restart level so over here and passing
the restart level
passing over here too because after two
seconds i want that to restart and over
here i'm going to say false because i
don't want this to loop and be an
infinite loop and spawn over and over
and over again
the last step over here is inside of our
restart level we simply need to call you
gameplay statics so
check out the statex and over here
open level
and simply we can pass the name of the
level or we can do this i can pass this
and i can say the name of the level
instead of passing the name i can say
here with a star
get world like that and over here get
the name there you go
and voila this world is going to get the
name
of the current level that we are in
and it is going to paste it over here
i'm going to compile this and while i'm
compiling i am going to explain what is
going on
inside of here i don't think there is
nothing to explain because we already
explained that inside of our runner
character we attached here the
on begin overlap for the capsule
collider that's everything what we did
and over here we're testing if we have
the other actor meaning we have collided
with something so the other actor is not
equal to null and there you go the build
has succeeded so our game is done
and over here we have the other actor we
have collided with something so
try to cast that other actor into a wall
spike or a spike basically meaning try
to test if the other actor is the wall
spike or if the other actor is the spike
is that true is that the case basically
this is what we're asking
and if we have either of these so if we
have a wall spike or if we have a spike
meaning they are not equal to null we
are going to get the mesh and deactivate
it we are also going to set the
visibility of the mesh to false so that
we don't see it anymore we cannot move
inside of our game so that when we press
the buttons we will not be able to move
because over here if you remember only
if we can move then we're going to have
the move add the movement to the player
and then over here we're going to
restart the level this is the signature
how you restart the level so we need to
pass this timer handle even though we're
not using it passing this referring to
this class this is the function i want
to be called after two seconds and no i
don't want it to loop i don't want it to
repeat over and over again and over here
simply calling gameplay statics open
level passing the level name to reload
the level and that's pretty much it we
are done so if i hit the play button
right now when we you know collide with
the spikes or this wall so now when the
wall touches me there we go the
character has disappeared now we
restarted the level and if i collide
with one of the spikes so
come on let's try here is one of the
spikes there you go bam
i've also died and there we go this is
our game let's try it out again again
let's run let's run
and
anyways you get the point
congratulations for making it till the
end of this game if you like this video
hit the like button subscribe to the
channel all the good stuff because it
will help me out you know i'm trying to
spread the word about my wisdom and
just kidding but anyways you get the
point so i don't have anything else to
say if you like this you have more
tutorials in my game development academy
thank you for watching again and i will
see you guys in the next video